نتنياهو ووزيره للدفاع ومدير المخابرات
اخفقوا جميعا في اطلاع الحكومه الامنيه
المصغره في اسرائيل على الخطر الاستراتيجي
الذي مثلته شبكه انفاق حماس قبيل حرب
2014 تلك خلاصه تقرير مراقب الدوله
الاسرائيلي الذي حمل المستويين العسكري
والسياسي المسؤوليه عن جوانب القصور التي
اعترت اداء جيش الاحتلال خلال تلك الحرب
التي صورها نتنياهو انذاك على انها ستكون
خاطفه وغير مكلفه غير انها استمرت 51 يوما
واسفرت عن مقتل 67 جنديا اسرائيليا واسر
اخرين تابعات هذه الخطوه وردود الفعل
السياسيه والعسكريه من جانب اسرائيل
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه نناقشها بعد التقرير
التالي ب 18 صفحه فصل المراقب العام في
اسرائيل اخفاقات ساستها وعسكريه في
التعامل مع خطر انفاق المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في غزه قبل الحرب وخلالها وقد وجه سهام
انتقاداته الى رئيس ال زراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه مشي علون ورئيس هيئه
الاركان بيني جانتس ورئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه افيف كوخافي فهمهم
باخفاء معلومات عن اعضاء المجلس الوزاري
المصغر وقال ان نقاشات المجلس لم ترقى الى
عرض الانفاق باعتبارها خطرا استراتيجيا
داهما وذهب التقرير الى اتهام الجيش بعدم
اعداد خطه عسكريه لمواجهه الانفاق وبتصير
في اعداد وتدريب قواته لمواجه هذا الخطر
وكشف التقرير ايضا عن اخفاق مدون على صعيد
شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه في تحديد عدد
الانفاق الهجوميه والتحذير من
خطرها فعجز الجيش عن الكشف ولو عن نفق
واحد وكان كل ما اكتشفه محض صدفه وبعد شن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هجمات منها وخلافا
لما روج له نتنياهو وصحبه بعد الحرب فان
التقرير يؤكد ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم ينجح
في تدمير حتى نصف ما كان بحوزه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من انفاق تراشق الساسه والعسكر
في اسرائيل عشيه نشر التقرير بالاتهامات
عن دور كل طرف في الاخفاقات ومع ذلك ليس
لتقرير المراقب الاسرائيلي سلطه محاسبه
المقصرين ولا يبدو انه سيزعزع اركان
توليفه نتنياهو لكن فحواه ستظل ذخيره في
يد خصومه السياسيين يهددون ويبتز بها راس
السلطه متى
شاؤوا كانت الانف فق مفاجاه الحرب على غزه
صيف عام
2014 واثبتت فاعليتها باعتبارها سلاح رعب
استراتيجيا اذ مكنت رجال المقاومه من
تنفيذ عمليات تسلل نوعيه خلف خطوط الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتكبيده خسائر في الارواح فضلا
عن انها نجحت ولاول مره في تحييد سلاح
المدرعات الاسرائيلي وكانت منطلقا لقنص
واسر جنود من ميدان
المعركه لم تحقق اسرائيل انتصارا في الحرب
التي كان يفترض من منظورها ان تكون حربا
خاطفه ونوعيه وغير مكلفه فكانت اطول حرب
تخوضها وفي المقابل لم ترفع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه العلم الابيض كما تمنت
[تصفيق]
اسرائيل بعد عامين ونصف العام على انتهاء
الحرب تقول اسرائيل ان لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه 15 نفقا هجوميا تخترق الحدود
مع قطاع غزه وازاء هذا الواقع فان اسرائيل
تقف امام خيارين احلاهما مر فاما ان تبادر
الى تدمير الانفاق والانجرار الى مواجهه
جديده في غزه واما ان تتريث وتجاز في
ابقاء عنصر المفاجاه في يد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لشن هجمات عبر هذه
الانفاق من غزه انضم الينا الدكتور عدنان
ابو عامر استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
الامه ومن تل ابيب ايال عليمه مراسل
الشؤون العسكريه في راديو اسرائيل مرحبا
بكما سيد ايال ما وزن
جهاز مراقب الدوله في بنيه النظام السياسي
الاسرائيلي وما هي حدود
سلطاته الواقع لا اعتقد ان هذا التقرير قد
يؤدي الى تغيير فيما يتعلق بال هذا
سنناقشه لاحقا انا اسال
عن انا اسال عن الجوانب الخاصه
ببنيه النظام السياسي وموضع مراقب الدوله
في هذا هذا
النظام
اي مراقبه
الدوله في بعض
الاحيان قد تكون له اهميه من ناحيه الضجه
التي يستطيع اثارتها في هذه في هذا
التقرير لم يوجه او لم يتخذ توصيات شخصيه
ضد اي من المسؤولين لذلك الوزن لهذا
التقرير ربما يكمن في الضجه او التاثير
الذي قد يحدثه في الساحه يعني هل نف من
ذلك ان مراقب الدوله في اسرائيل ليست له
سلطات لا قيمه لتقارير التي
يصدرها الا الا اذا كان قد اصدر توصيات
شخصيه بحق اي من المسؤولين كما كان في
الماضي وكما قد ادى في السابق الى بعض
التغييرات الى استقاله شخصيات في مناصب
عليا ولكن هذه المره لا توجد هناك توصيات
شخصيه ضد اي من المسؤولين التقرير هو
خطيره فيما يتعلق باداء المستوى السياسي
والعسكري ولكن لا توجد هناك توصيات خاصه
ان وزير الدفاع السابق لم يعد يشغل هذا
المنصب كذلك رئيس هيئه الاركان لم يعد
يشغل هذا المنصب السؤال يتعلق ربما بمكانه
رئيس الوزراء في هذه المرحله وخاصه خصه
انه
لم يقول او لم يوصي باتخاذ ال اجراءات
فهذا الامر مطوق ربما للقوى العامله داخل
الحلبه السياسيه الداخليه سيد عدنان ابو
عامر في المقابل في ظل غياب مثل هذه
الاجهزه او على الاقل ليست هناك تقارير
معلنه من الجانب الفلسطيني عن اداء
المقاومه هل يمكن اعتبار ما جاء في تقرير
المراقب الاسرائيلي على انه شهاده نجاح
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في حرب عام 2014
شوف من المؤكد ان مثل هذا التقرير الرسمي
الاسرائيلي لم يكن يقصد بالضروره توزيع
نياشين واوسمه على المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
لكنه من حيث لا يقصد قدم شهاده تقدير بين
قوسين كبيرين لاداء المقاومه امام الجيش
الاسرائيلي واظهر الجيش وحكومته كما كان
في بالضبط كما قال احد المعلقين
الاسرائيليين في ملابسه الداخليه امام
الراي العام الاسرائيلي التقرير
الاسرائيلي رغم ما فيه من كثافه من الماده
العلميه والمعطيات الاستخباريه والمعطيات
الرقميه بالعكس ربما يكون اكثر قوه من
تقريب فينوغراد في حرب لبنان 2006 وتقرير
جراند في حرب 1973 لذلك محاوله التقليل
الاسرائيلي من اهميه التقرير قد تبدو من
خلال صفقه قد تكون بين نتنياهو ومعد
التقرير قاضي متقاعد شبير حتى لا يتم
تقديم استقالات او اقالات حكوميه واضح ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه خرجت باستخلاص
بالتاكيد من اداء المقاومه خلال الحرب
الاخيره لكن ليس بالضروره كل ما يعلم يقال
ان صح التعبير والمقاومه الفلسطينيه لديها
من الاستخلاصات والدروس الكثيره التي ظهرت
خلال الحروب الثلاثه الاخيره وربما ما شهد
بها العدو الاسرائيلي في التقرير الاخير
اكد ان بعد مرور 30 شهرا تقريبا المقاومه
فلسطين لديها ما يقرب من 15 نفقا اجتز
حدود اسرائيل وهذا لوحده قد يكون شهاده
التقدير لاداء المقاومه الفلسطين وقدرته
على تفوق وتجاوز كل الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
معلومه فقط صغيره ان اسرائيل انفقت ما
يقرب من اربع مليارات شيكل خلال ال 30
شهرا لمقاومه موضوع الانفاق الهجوميه ومع
ذلك تعترف بملء الفم ان لدينا عجزا واخفاق
حتى ان بالامس لواء كبيرا مثل يعكوف
عميدرور اكد ان اسرائيل للاسف لا تمتلك
قبه حديديه لمواجهه الانفاق تحت الارضيه
اللواء كو يوم توف ساميا رئيس المنطقه
الجنوبيه السابق قال بصوره واضحه اننا
امام اخفاق استراتيجي خطير اخفاق بنيوي
معلوماتي استخباري جعلنا نذهب الى الحرب
بدون معطيات معلوماتيه استخباريه ولكن دع
دعنا اولا نطلع على ردود الفعل المختلفه
التي صدرت بعد هذا التقرير اعتبرت حركتا
حماس والجهات تقرير مراقب الدوله
الاسرائيلي اقرارا بفشل العدوان والحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه عام
2014 بينما اطلقت المعارضه الاسرائيليه
دعوات لتشكيل لجنه تحقيق رسميه في اخفاقات
هذه الحرب من جهته صرح رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي جادي ايزنكوت تعقيبا على تقرير
مراقب الدوله بان جيشه قد استخلص العبر
وبل ور خطه لتحسين قدراته القتاليه في غزه
وتحقيق الانتصار اما رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو فقال ان الاختبار الحقيقي لنتائج
الحرب هو في الهدوء غير المسبوق الذي يسود
البلدات الحدوديه مع غزه وقال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي الاسبق عمير بيرتس ان تقرير
مراقب الدوله عرض صوره قاتمه تكشف محاولات
لتنص نتنياهو من مسؤولياته وتحدثت عائلات
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي عما تناوله التقرير
ع تناوله التقرير من اخفاقات في اداره
الحرب في المجلس الو الوزاري واذرعه الامن
ورات ان الاسرائيليين يستحقون قياده تتحلى
بالمسؤوليه سيد ايال
عليمه بدا من التقرير ان رئيس الوزراء
انذاك بنيامين نتنياهو ورئيس الوزراء
الحالي كان في عجله من امره يريد ان يذهب
الى الحرب باي ثمن حتى
ولو لم يعطي لهذه الحرب الاعداد الكافي و
يطلع مجلس الوزري الوزري المصغر على
المعلومات الضروريه لكي يضع استراتيجيه
مناسبه لهذه الحرب وانه حتى اوهمهم بان
حماس غير معنيه لا تريد تصعيد الامور
وانها غير قادره على مواجهه اسرائيل وان
الحرب ستكون خاطفه الى اي مدى يمكن محاسبه
نتنياهو على
هذا في الواقع اولا من الناحيه السياسيه
هذا هو السؤال الا اذا قررت في نهايه
الامر الاوساط السياسيه الحزبيه تشكيل او
تعيين لجنه التحقيق فان الامر يختلف تماما
ولذلك قد تكون انعكاسات خطيره بالنسبه
لبقاء الحكومه او بقاء نتنياهو شخصيا ولكن
في هذه المرحله طالما لم تكن هناك اي
توصيات شخصيه نرى الاصوات في المعارضه
السؤال اذا قد تتجسد الاصوات الى خطوات
عمليه في هذه المرحله يبدو انها لن تؤدي
الى ذلك لحسابات سياسيه داخليه ولكن لا
اعتقد بان احد يحاول التخفيف من خطوره هذا
التقطير رغم هذه ال التحليلات فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا السياسيه الخطيره التحقيق هو
خطير وخطير للغايه ربما الدليل على ذلك ال
الهزه الذي اح احدثته او احدثتها
هذه المعركه في الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي قام
باستخلاص العبر باتخاذ كل الوسائل ب توجيه
مبالغ طائله لمواجهه قضيه الانفاق لا احد
يحاول الاستخفاف في خطوره ط على ذكر قضيه
الانفاق دكتور
عدنان التقرير لم ياتي على ذكر الوضع
الراهن لمساله الانفاق هذه وهل ما زالت
سلاحا استراتيجيا بيد المقاومه يمكن
التعويل عليه في حروب القادمه وربما هناك
اصوات كثيره من بين المحللين والمراقبين
تشير الى قرب حرب قادمه على قطاع غزه
مشابهه لما جرى في عام 2014 ما هو وضع
الانفاق
حاليا تبدو الاشاره مهمه الى القول ان
التقرير لم يتم الكشف عنه كليا هو تم
الكشف عن فصلين خاصين بموضوع الانفاق من
جهه وكيفيه اداره الحرب لكن الواضح ان
الاسرائيليين يعتقدون جازمين ان العام
2017 كما قال قائد الجيش ازن كوت هو
العامل الواضح والمهمه الاساسيه في مواجهه
انفاق حماس في غزه والقول بان هناك م
عشرات المعدات الهندسيه على طول حدود قطاع
غزه الشرقيه من شماله الى جنوبه تعمل ليل
الى نهار في محاوله العثور والكشف وتعقب
هذا انفاق هذا يعطي دلاله واضحه على اننا
امام بالفعل تهديد حقيقي للمناطق الجنوبيه
في اسرائيل ومنطقه غلاف غزه الشكاوى
المتواصله بشان سماع اصوات المستوطنين لا
حفريات تحت الارض ووجود شبهات امكانيه
الصول انفاق الى ما بعد الحدود الفلسط
فلسطينيه الاسرائيليه هذا دليل اخر على ان
هناك تهيز حقيقيا السؤال الذي يطرح الان
في الاروقه الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه هل
تنتظر اسرائيل ان تصل هذه الانفاق الى ما
بعد الحدود وتنفيذ عمليات مفاجئه من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتسجيل صوره انتصار
في داخل العمق الاسرائيلي ام ان اسرائيل
تفاجئها بضربه استباقيه كما جرت العاده في
بعض الحروب السابقه ل منعها وحيون دون
تسجيل هذه الضربه الاستباقيه هذا مساله
مرهونه بالمعطيات الميدانيه ورغم وجود او
عدم وجود ان صح التعبير رغبه عند الجانبين
المقاومه واسرائيل بالذهاب الى هذه الحرب
على الاقل فتره مدى المنظور لكن عودتنا
المنطقه على ذهاب الجانبين ذهاب العدوين
الى حروب لا يريدانها ولكن تفرضها الواقع
الميدانيه طيب ال الى اي مدى سيد ايال
عليمه يمكن ان يؤدي هذا التقرير الى الجام
رغبات الحرب التي تعتري اذهان الساسه
الاسرائيليين من ان لاخر يعني عام 2014
مثلت الانفاق مفاجاه مدويه للجيش
الاسرائيلي كشفت كثيرا من اوجه القصور في
عمل الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه هل تذهب
اسرائيل مجددا الى الحرب ثم تكتشف خلال
هذه الحرب ان هناك سلاحا جديدا طورته
المقاومه لا لا لا اعتقد ان هذا التقرير
يجب ان يفسر بهذا الاتجاه بمعنى ان
اسرائيل تستعد حاليا لمعركه قديمه في او
او او اتيه في قطاع غزه في الواقع
لا يبدو لي ان اسرائيل غير معنيه بمثل هذه
المعركه ما ان حماسه غير معنيه بمثل هذه
المعركه صحيح هناك بعض التجهيزات التي
وبعض الاعمال التي تجرع على امتداد السياج
الفاصل بين اسرائيل وقطاع غزه وذلك ربما
عندما تقول ان القياده الاسرائيليه غير
معنيه بهذه الحرب فان هذا القول يمكن ان
يرد عليه التقرير نفسه تقرير يشير الى ان
احدا لم يعمل على تحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه
في قطاع غزه
بما كان يمكن ان يعني يجهد الحرب من قبل
ان تبدا كان يمكن تجنب هذه الحرب اذا كانت
الاوضاع الانسانيه في غطاء غزه افضل مما
كانت عليه حتى اللحظه الرهينه وعقب مرور
نحو ثلاث سنوات على هذه الحرب لم يتطور
الامر في قطاع غزه انسانيا ولم تخفف
اسرائيل
قبضتها وهذه ربما النقطه المركزيه
والاساسيه بنظري فيما يتعلق بهذا التقرير
مراقب الدوله يقول بان المستوى العسكري
تبنى بشكل كامل الخيارات العسكريه الخطط
التي عرضها امامه عرضتها امامه القياده
العسكريه دون ان ينظر في الحلول السياسيه
ودون ان ياخذ بنظر الاعتبار
احتمال الاوضاع الانسانيه في قطاع غزه هذه
هذه النقطه ربما تثير عمات الاستفهام وعدم
الارتياح ربما هل كانت هناك وسيله لمنع
نشوب هذه المعركه هذا السؤال مطوك لا
اعتقد بان الوضع الراهن يقضي بان اسرائيل
تتجه الى مثل هذه المعركه بسبب الاوضاع
الانسانيه في قطاع غزه التي لم تتغير او
بسبب ما نراه على امتداد الحدود
الاسرائيليه وقطاع غزه دكتور عدنان الى اي
مدى نال هذا التقرير من صوره الجيش الا
الاسرائيلي وجهاز المخابرات الذين ا تحيط
بهما هاله او يصر الاسرائيليون على ان
يحيطه بهاله من الكفاءه
[موسيقى]
والفاعليه لعل الحرب الاخيره على غزه منحت
الاسرائيليين فرصه للمس بما يسمونه البقره
المقدسه وهو الجيش بعد ان كان النيل من
المؤسسه الحاكمه الكنيس البرلمان الوزاره
امر معتد عليه لكن الجيش ظهر انه غير قادر
على توفير الامن لجنوده فضلا عن توفير امن
لمواطنيه في داخل العمق الاسرائيلي الجيش
الذي لم يستطع ان يوقف تمدد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه المقاتلين من الانفاق الى داخل
اسرائيل وتم اسر جنوده من داخل مجنزرات
ودبابات واسحبهم الى داخل قطاع غزه هذا ال
جيش لم يعد يؤتمن على قياده الدوله وحمايه
الدوله من اخطار تفوق اضعاف مضاعف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولذلك كانت الصوره
مهتزه جدا كثيرا في التقرير بالعكس
التقرير كما تقول بعض المسودات خف كثيرا
من انتقاله المواجهه الى الجيش واصبح هناك
حاله من تبادل الاتهامات ليس فقط بين
السياسه والعسكر وانما بين العسكر انفسهم
بين الجيش كمستوى عسكري عمل نص دقيقه لو
تكررت متى يتعلم العرب من عدوهم ان
يحاسبوا المخطئين ها هو تقرير تابع
للحكومه الاسرائيليه ينتقد رئيس الوزراء
وينتقد وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان وجهاز
المخابرات بينما يشيع عند العرب مقوله لا
صوت فوق صوت المعركه بما تضيع معه
المسائله للمخطئين باختصار لو
تكرمت قل لي استاذ محمود متى يحصل ذلك ولك
سو ري كسر شوف بالعاده العرف العربي الدار
السياسي قد لا يعني قد لا يذهب كثيرا الى
مساله الاقالات وتوجيه انتقادات و لكن
ازعم وقد زعمي قد يكون خاطئا ان المقاومه
فلسطينيه استخلصت دروسا كثيره في الحرب
الاخيره وربما لدي بعض المعطيات التي لا
تصلح ان تنشر الى العام ان هناك استخلاص
حقيقي واجراء لجان مراجعه وتقويم للعمل
الميداني وربما اعتراف اسرائيل بان هناك
حاله من تنميه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
واستخلاص دروس اخرى كان شاهدا على هذا
التقويم شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
وعلى سواري كسر ايضا الدكتور عدنان ابو
عامر استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه الامه
كان معنا من غزه واشكر ضيفنا من تل ابيب
اي ال عليمه مراسل الشؤون العسكريه في
راديو اسرائيل